okay for kids watching this is probably
not for you
three two that's out of the way felony
murder
felony murder are you [ __ ] me
are you [ __ ] me we have a show
tonight we have jocko william coming on
we'll talk about all this and we have
clips
i'm sorry i just couldn't wait i don't
know about you i was so i had a
pit in my stomach last night i was
physically sick to my stomach
and i woke up physically sick to my
stomach
this morning and by the way it doesn't
mean that we weren't sick to our stomach
when we saw the george floyd video
because we all did
but felony murder for officer i think
it's garrett rolfe
garrett rolf who shot ray shard brooks
in atlanta you have a d.a who charged
him with
felony murder do you know what felony
murder is folks
you know what felony murder is felony
murder is when murder is tacked on to a
crime already occurring in pro a felony
is already taking place it's already in
process like
like armed robbery goes wrong right
you're just planning on robbing a bank
you're not planning on shooting anybody
but oh and then you end up shooting some
that's felony murder
please do tell me what [ __ ] felony
that officer was committing before he
fired his gun on somebody who had
stolen his taser beating the crap out of
him and then
then tried to shoot him with it oh
that's right i guess the felony would be
trying to cuff the man
who's a serial felon who abused his own
children rashard brooks
a serial felon child abuser uh and false
imprisonment likely kidnapper i don't
know the exact charges but you can look
at his rap sheet
and uh was going to go back to jail for
a long time remember i made that bet
with stacey abrams on twitter
how much do you want to bet that this
has nothing to do with a dui
has to do with a rap sheet that would
make a dui more severe which by the way
are the most dangerous pullovers
that often happen with cops someone
doesn't want to go back to the klink
they have nothing to lose
so i guess the officers felony was
arresting a man who was putting everyone
else in danger
is that it i guess the officer's felony
was conducting a field sobriety test
on someone who by the way didn't pull
over into a wendy's
parking space like oh man i'm just i
have had
too much to drink and i'm going to do
respond no he fell asleep in the
drive-through
line to the point it took two officers
to wake
him up is that the felony felony murder
and by the way here's something else
what do you think happens if you watch
that video and there's only one officer
which is the case
most of the time one of them got spiked
on his head punch
in the face a taser stolen used against
him and they didn't just shoot him sorry
my arm's getting tired i apologize for
this but not really
i don't know if i can hold it can i hold
it this way can you see me okay
i look like crap i get it it's the
morning i apologize but not really we
can do the show tonight when i
brush my hair spiked an officer on his
head
beat the [ __ ] out of them stole a
taser and they didn't shoot him always
running away they only shot him once he
turned to aim a taser
oh i guess the felony according to d.a
was
um using using a taser was uh sorry
sorry
no no there is no felony because the d.a
said that the officer
could not be in uh in fear of serious
bodily injury at that point
when two weeks earlier the d.a said that
a taser is a deadly weapon
here's the thing
this is a line in the sand and and i
feel and i and i will tell you and i
would love
tell me what you think we should do i am
i would love to start maybe a gofundme
but we would need
many many tens of millions of dollars so
every cop who wants to walk off the
force at this point can do so
and we can take care of him and i'm sure
my lawyer is not going to be happy that
i even suggested that don't worry i
haven't started the gofundme
i do the show we reach millions of
people every single show and i feel like
it's not enough because
we are at a point in our country right
now you can only line up three ways
okay you either believe that the officer
who shot the man who beat the [ __ ] out
of him and stole his taser aimed at him
serial felon guy who leaves children
you believe that the officer should be
put to death
because that's the penalty okay
potentially
potentially for felony murder in georgia
so you either a believe that
officer rolf should be put to death
should be executed
b believe that this is completely
impermissible
or c you're a coward and you're just as
bad as bee and you know what this is
something people
wanna wanna come after me and sue me
okay i let everyone on my team
know here at loudouth crowder i said if
you don't pick
b if you don't say that this is
impermissible cowardice is not
cowardice is not tolerated on this team
i will provide you with generous
severance
there's the door
we are not at a point in this country
where remaining neutral is a possibility
and you know what bothers me more than
the leftists out there who've been very
smart strategically
is first off the repub donald trump what
are you going to do something
when are you going to stop the boot
looking the bootlicking
president come on something here there
are
blocks of cities being taken over
against people's will
what have republicans done unless there
is there were riots before donald trump
and that's a big reason donald trump was
elected
and now republicans aren't doing [ __ ]
and if you don't start picking it up you
do not deserve our vote
sorry maga crowd sorry okay crowd
he's not my king okay i think the guy's
done a lot of good work but i
am so disappointed in this
administration and i'm so disappointed
in republicans
i don't even know that my vote makes
that much of a difference at this point
and unless you are going out there and
championing the cause of people who have
the right to defend themselves
because right now you can't have a
neighborhood watch
we know that that's not allowed you
can't call the cops because they can't
do anything
cops can't have guns we don't want that
cops can't use chokeholds even though if
a cop could use a chokehold and apply it
properly
everyone in the race shark brooks
conflict would still be alive and now a
taser
is a deadly weapon if an officer has it
but if an officer if it's used against
an officer it's not and he'll be put on
death
[ __ ] road republicans
in this state you need to make it clear
that americans have the right to defend
their homes and property and their
loved ones or you don't deserve our vote
felony murder imagine imagine that's
your dad
or mom if they lowered the pt
requirements
imagine
what really bothers me is republicans
and all of these christians
who uh don't get mad
like there was never a time that that
jesus threw over some tables at the
temple
i think it's table tossing time
what time is it it's table tossing time
because they're selling lattes
in the place of worship for crying out
loud you see these christians oh it's
just love and you know what actually
this is true
i was planning on i'm starting a day of
prayer
in dc where we kneel in prayer uh and
stand to pledge because
no man should kneel to another man as
christians we don't believe in kneeling
that's
that's deeply rooted in our history both
as christians and americans
uh but the prayer has changed
the prayer is no longer for unity the
prayer is for safety
and swift revolut resolution so oh you
two will take that wrong
swift resolution right now
any anyone think it's table flipping
time at this point
felony murder and is this conspiratorial
i look up
there's no possible way this may unless
they're trying to overcharge so that
when these officers get off which they
inevitably do hopefully someone
intervenes here
because i don't think any person who's a
human being with two brain cells to rub
together wants
this officer to be put to death then
there'll be more riots
then it'll get more violent no justice
no peace yep you're right
no justice no peace no justice no peace
you don't get
to put a cop on death row for firing
a firearm at a drunken serial violent
felon
child abuser who beat their asses stole
their weapon
and used it against him that's right
this
is the great and do i am not saying this
is a worse travesty uh injustice than
george floyd
yep yeah yeah you know why because
everyone agreed that the cop needed to
be punished for george floyd
manslaughter great then they overcharged
move at the murder charges don't know if
that can stick don't know if you can
prove intent
wonder why they did that there was a
moment that was taken where we were all
in agreement that could have unified the
country
and it's been cracked on
and this is where we are and we talk and
i see the news well you know what we
need
we do need to understand the civil
unrest because black men are being
hunted down in the streets and
no no no and i know everyone hears the
stat everyone here's the statistic
because i've talked about it ad nauseam
we have some more change my mind's
coming next week
um that you know nine
black guy nine unarmed black guys were
shot by officers last year
how many white guys 19. people oh yeah
but they make up only uh about uh
10 to 50 percent of the population but
that's true but they commit
60 of the homicides black americans
young black males are 37 times more
likely this might be banned because it's
fbi crime statistics but let me be
really clear here
not making it a racial thing not making
it a racial supremacy thing
making it an accurate statistics thing
because you said black lives
matter people look around and go oh my
god violent riot rioting literally 400
officers killed
25 people killing these violent riots
and losing over 25 million dollars in
property damage in minneapolis what's
happening like black lives matter black
lives matter black lives matter we go
home a second we need to find some peace
here we need to find some justice and
community what do we do why is there all
those violence why do people acting like
criminals and then you go black lives
matter black lives matter you know
what's going to happen
people will say oh all this [ __ ]
is because of black lives matter and
congratulations youtube and big tech
in censoring the message you've now
created more
racists you're so busy trying to censor
was it zero hedge and the federalist
comment section
and featuring takashi 69
who uses the n-word repeatedly despite
not being black
and a talentless piece of [ __ ] who
sexually abused a minor
physically abused his girlfriend for
years
and uh uh what racketeering choke to die
anyway the point is that's featured on
the youtube trending list right
youtube's really clear about their
priorities congratulations youtube
twitter facebook
you've created the extremists at this
point
because people like me for a long time
say no no it's not a black white thing
black lives matter
black lives matter well hold on a second
let's talk about all that's racist
that's racist hold on a second this
officer felony murder
felony murder put him on death row
because officers
are hunting down black men and killing
them in the streets despite the fact
that there's a higher percentage
of police officers who are black than
the general percentage of the population
of america
and it's really hard to find statistics
based on on race some crime statistics
because
they only do it in the in the media
publicly when they can use it for black
victimhood status and i mean that when
they say
officers are hunting down black people
in the streets and killing them
and you can hear that exact phrase from
the young turks
you can hear that exact phrase from don
lemon
okay now if people believe that
every single american should be outraged
if people believe that officers are
hunting down people solely because
they're black in the streets and killing
them but that is not happening
so in trying to combine all these
statistics regarding homicide the rates
that homicides uh which occur between
races
uh how many officers died per year how
many officers die at the hands of
a black man do you know how much more
likely an officer is to be killed by a
black
criminal than to shoot or kill
an armed black man 18 and a half times
a police officer in the united states is
18 and a half times
more likely to be shot
by a black man a criminal
during apprehension than he is to kill
an unarmed black man
you know what i've always tried to be
this voice
but here's here's the truth guys and
i'll be talking about youtube a whole
lot more because there's been a lot of
conversations behind the scenes isn't
that right youtube where they've made it
very clear that my view is on
immigration that it's about ideas and
values and the naturalization of regard
i've said right that i would much rather
have for example
um a honduran or a cuban-american
patriot
who comes here and loves the united
states and what it's about than
a swedish immigrant or german immigrant
who wants to come here
and vote in socialism well that's an
unacceptable viewpoint
that youtube that's borderline content
where do you think people go
when this video is seen as borderline
content
youtube where do you think people go
it's not ben shapiro or myself sending
people down an alt-right rabbit hole
it's you saying that these views which
are entirely statistically
substantiated are extremist views
and i've always tried to be the reason i
say that is sorry it's a little bit free
flow right now we do have the show
tonight with jocko willing we'll be
talking about chokeholds spoiler alert
big fan uh especially now more
chokeholds choke hold forever you get a
choke and you get a chokehold
and you get a chokehold everybody gets a
chokehold because we can't use tasers
so
i've always tried to be the voice of
reason and when people used to say when
barack obama was president oh there goes
our country and i would say you know
what listen
no you you get some bad guys you get
some good guys the good thing is we have
checks and balances in this country and
we can fix it
uh when people talked about there's
going to be an armed revolution i'd say
no no but you know what
hey let me be really clear youtube i'm
not telling people to go
out there and shoot people in the
streets but for the first time in my
life i think a civil war
is very possible let me explain to you
why because it is not an irrational
okay let me frame this thing exactly
let's talk about jazz
jazz razzmatazz jazz peaceful chaz
right with that uh razz warlord and
they're hanging out ar15s to 15 year
olds if you haven't seen this clip
where's the felony charge there
it's the razz show loophole um
you have six now three square blocks of
the united states that have been taken
over
by violent extremists uh
by the way leaders with no elections uh
enforcement police with no
accountability
no freedom of the press no free speech
allowed in jazz that's the liberal
that's the liberal utopia
jazz where's bernie speaking i thought
democratic socialism was the democratic
socialism there was a democratic
socialism when people are getting shaken
down
no democrat speaking it's a summer of
love tell it to the business owners
there so let's look at that chaz let me
ask you this
i've never thought that we were a point
in our country that we could have a
civil war
or that it would of course that would be
appropriate and i'm not even saying that
a civil war would be appropriate now but
i will say this
felony murder and when you have a place
like
jazz sorry chop now because they're
[ __ ] and they understand that calling
it chas is an autonomous zone
actually makes it illegal we're just
actually protest by the way could you
send some canned goods and uh some phone
chargers
no so in jazz uh
do you have a place
a communist anti-american insurrection
that was not elected that is basically
now taking over
a portion of what is supposed to be free
america
against residents will
who are silenced and intimidated into
not speaking out
and they are protecting this zone with
guns
they have taken over an area of a city
and they are protecting it
with guns would it be an irrational
response
for american citizens to take back that
portion of their city with guns
when the police won't do anything not
saying they should i'm not advocating it
but once upon a time i would have looked
at that and said well come on guys
let's have a let's have a let's have
some kind of an equitable arrangement
there should be a response that's
tantamount to
but what is equal to that
what is equal force when a city is taken
over by people and protected with guns
it has to be take it
oh take it back with guns let me ask you
this what if it's your neighborhood
let's say right now i know a lot of you
are smart enough to not live in big
cities anymore despite the fact that the
left wants to hurt us in the big cities
and put us in public transit i read
about that at fox news uh nine years ago
and said it was crazy um
let's say it's your neighborhood and
you're going home tonight i have a wife
who's sick some people know that if you
follow me on instagram or social media
she had
gbs and she's she's going to walk
fine eventually
but it raises my antenna so let's say
it's your neighborhood and you're trying
to get home
today to your house that you've paid for
and you can't there's a barricade with
some [ __ ]
and a mask and some buddies with ar-15s
who tell you that you need to present
identification
and maybe in that neighborhood is your
business and you've got to pay a fee
your little poll tax for antifa dimitude
let's say it's your neighborhood
your entire neighborhood put a primer on
it and barricade
and now it's been taken over by the
extremists like chaz
you've seen the results of chas go watch
some videos it looks like east berlin
not only businesses but residences have
been ransacked
what would you do what would you do
comment does that make you an extremist
does that make you an extremist if it is
your neighborhood that has been taken
over without a vote against your will
and the government your mayor and your
governor have made it clear
that there is no cavalry coming over
that hill
and for you to enter your own house you
have to go past a guy with an ar-15 who
was demanding complete defunding of
police
what would you do
i'm telling you just like i said please
stop
the riots please stop this is not going
to be good
when you want every reaction has an
equal and opposite reaction
and i used to say i really don't think
there's any risk of a civil war because
listen obamacare
terrible awful come from canadian
healthcare you can watch my video you
can watch the history that i've had with
healthcare and i've fought against it
but an equal and opposite reaction
wouldn't be to take over cities with
guns
that's what i have referred to as
militia extremists
and i still stand by that but i don't
think you're a militia extremist
when people have taken over your city
with
guns if you respond
with an equal and opposite reaction in
your commit with your own property
especially when now we've made it clear
that the people who we pay who our tax
dollars pay to protect us
can't even try and do their job in the
face of a serial violent felon who's
violently assaulted two of them stolen a
deadly weapon and used it against them
without fear of being put on death
row
you either believe that this officer
deserves death
well no i think he should be punished
but that's not the charge
that's not the charge death penalty
this is impermissible this is a line in
the sand or you're a coward
and any any christian out there who
wants to do the the agape [ __ ]
don't put on my team jersey
because you know what if you do that you
don't speak a good
man maybe he's a jack we don't know
but there's no i would bet that he was a
really bad cop there's bad history i
know now they're trying to say oh he
kicked a man when he was dead while he
was down but
how much you here i'll place another bet
how much do you want to bet that's not
true
how much do you want just like i said
when they pulled over uh uh
right well i didn't pull him over he
went like homer simpson and they found
him in a
wendy's drive-through line it wasn't
pulled over
that that would jostle him up one more
crack
i didn't remember what i was gonna say
i'm getting so angry about this
a good man potentially oh yeah i was
saying that how much you want to just
like i said there was more of the story
than
just some guy pulled into a wendy's
parking lot peacefully and he was shot
by cops
no no and then i saw the arrest i was
like oh how much do you want to bet
there's more to this than a dui there's
probably going back to the clink for a
long time turns out he was a child
abuser and i think was
might have only been out on coronavirus
um just like the kashi 69 right yeah
like piggy from lord of the flies all of
a sudden you're in prison you're bored
and then it's oh i can get out from
coronavirus
my asthma you hear it right my asthma i
would like to be free to go to beat my
kids more
just like i said there was more to that
story no one agreed to that bet and i
did i bet with stacey abrams my entire
social media platform youtube facebook
twitter instagram mailing list all of it
i said i will bet that
against your candidacy that he had
priors
who wants to take the bet any elected
official democrat any any elected
d.a abrams
bet here
the story that you're pushing is not
accurate that he kicked a man while he
was down and just said ha ha
i got me one and refused to provide
medical care
how much you want to bet that otherwise
just release that tape you have to tip
everything else why don't you release it
back to my point i do have to wrap this
up we have a show gosh it's 22 23
minutes
i'm sorry sorry listen maybe this means
something maybe it doesn't i just i i
had to get this off my chest i don't
know if anyone else
this is a very different feeling this is
different from any other
instance in the history of this country
for me
when they're about to put of course the
charges probably won't stick but if they
had their way would put
an officer a man who by all information
we have now that could change a good man
on death row to appease a mob
of bad men republicans you've let us
down
christians the church where's the church
you guys while there are riots in the
streets 25 million dollars in
property damage in minneapolis alone at
least hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars in damages and
repairs
across this country from riots
and pastors won't even pastors in many
states won't even hold
services in their own congregations
[ __ ]
and this doesn't come from a place of
hate it comes from a place
of righteous anger it is time to start
flipping some tables
people need to start earning our support
and to the agape christians right now
who think that it's the righteous thing
to do to stand by and go oh
i'm gonna go in my prayer closet and
just pray for he
just pray for healing for this country
right now when you could speak out
when a man could be put to death to
appease a mob of violent people
you are not righteous you are not doing
the right thing you are a coward
and if the jazz jazz situation
uh happens across the country
maybe in your cities of los angeles
maybe could pick any big city
guess what i will love you
i will pray for you just but you will
knock on that door that has been made of
brick
and i will not protect you
and neither should any other american
the left has tried to say silence is
murder silence is murder well
hold on i'm just not being silent
because you're like an officer is 18
times more likely to be
killed by a black man in a shooter black
like i just don't think that i think the
problem is we need police reform i just
don't think they buy it
black people are being hunted like i
don't think ray shark brooks was being
hunted silence is murder but i will tell
you this right now when a man
is sentenced to death for doing his job
even if imperfectly and when you have
cities in the united states of america
that
have been overtaken and are being
guarded by communists
with guns silence is cowardice
silence is consent
that includes senators congressmen media
members
presidents and people watching this
video mug club subscribers
if you choose to be silent i love you
i pray for you but i don't want you here
and if the [ __ ] goes down
none of the people who were vocal who
did the right thing
owe you any protection all right i'll
see you tonight jacques